you mentioned during the panel that you
get to see her mothering the ghost crew
but you know the last time we saw Hera
Jason are we going to get to see her
mothering him you know I I think I have
to say no comment on that one I think I
haven't been given the go-ahead to to
make any official comments on that one
well kind of on that note going back to
Rebels
um you know there's a lot of episodes to
watch which Hera episode do you think
that fans should revisit before watching
Ahsoka gosh I'm so bad at remembering
you know exact episodes and titles and
things like that but I would say
um going back to not even on Rebels but
the bad bash kind of starting with that
I mean that for me was was so great to
get to see her as a child because
anytime as an actor if you can figure
out what your character went through as
a child it's so instrumental in figuring
out kind of who they are as a person so
that was was really great for me to kind
of get to see that childlike joy in her
and her desire to kind of be up in the
air and all of that and then to get to
see in Rebels and so many episodes when
you get to see her really in her element
and fighting flying in her spaceship and
getting to do what she's been wanting to
do since she was such a little girl and
kind of the joy that that brings in her
and also as time goes on through the
series and how the stakes kind of grow
in different ways and Things become more
and more complex and emotional um
you know trying to figure out okay how
does she still get joy from that but
also you know bring in the the stakes
and the and the concern that she has for
this family that she's built
um so it's not specifically answering
your question but those are the episodes
that that were the most helpful are
there any specific episodes for Ahsoka
that you are most excited for fans to
see or maybe the ones that like
resonated with you
um of oh gosh
um it's going to be really hard to talk
about without giving things away
um but I would say every character goes
on quite the journey and different
episodes get to focus uh on different
aspects of you know what each character
is going through in different ways
um so I'm just happy that fans are going
to get something that they want out of
each and every person on the show it's
gonna it's gonna have their moments to
kind of give the fans something special
so going off that does that seem more
like each episode focuses maybe more on
one no I'm just making sure just making
sure no I'm definitely not definitely
not going that far but but I will just I
just saying that everyone gets kind of
their moment to shine I think for sure
yeah well thank you so much thank you so
much